(techno music)
- I'm really delighted to be able to
participate in this wonderful symposium.
What I would like to tell you today
is one particular aspect that is
absolutely essential for
normal brain development.
That is to have proper parenting.
We've heard from the wonderful talk from
BJ Casey right before me how important
proper nurturing from caregivers is
for normal mental health of the infant
that then become adult.
The question we've been
very interested in is
what makes a parent a parent?
If you think about
parenting involve
one, two, sometimes multiple adults
that take care of an infant.
The relationship is
completely asymmetrical,
there is really a very helpless individual
that requires a lot, a lot of
care for very, very long time.
What makes parents be parent?
It's I think a very interesting behavior,
a long-term behavior that has
a lot of emotional components.
This is a behavior also that is displayed
by many animal species.
It is absolutely essential
for the development
and the survival of the species.
So the idea is that there may be some
genetically pre-programed
neural signal in the brain.
And what we're interested in is really
trying to understand the neural basis.
What are the specific
neurons that are involved
in the control of parenting behavior,
in the display of parenting behavior?
And when is it that these
behavior actually goes wrong?
There are a number of circumstances
in which the behavior goes wrong.
This is one of I think, one of the most
really impressive or very surprising slide
related to mental illness.
That's the number of
psychiatric hospitalization
after childbirth.
You can see right at
the time of childbirth
this enormous peak in
psychiatric hospitalization of women.
These are patients that suffer
from post-partum psychosis.
This is very quite rare.
It requires hospitalization
because these women
have obsessive thought about
harming their children.
And therefore they require
very intensive care.
These
way less severe form which
is post-partum depression
that affect 10 to 20% of mother
and five to 10% of fathers in the US.
And these also comes right after birth
and result in an inability to emotionally
connect with children
and in affect impact parenting.
There are quite a number of risk factors,
_, life circumstances prior depression
and sensitivity to hormone changes.
As it turns out,
right at birth there's an enormous change
of hormonal levels in the young mother.
You can see here progesterone, estrogen,
oxytocin, prolactin, there's really
an enormous and very sudden
drop in hormone level.
Some people call these hormonal cows.
Women in particular that are sensitive
to these hormone fluctuation
have really difficulty
in coping with those changes.
How do we understand the positive
and the negative regulation
of parental behavior?
Well let's turn to animals.
So in animals
and human as well,
the primary care giver
is usually the mother.
And in animals and in
mammals in particular,
this makes a lot of sense
because in mammals the mother
nurtures the fetus, the embryo in utero
for a long period of time
and then is involved in lactation.
So really involve enormous
maternal resources
in nurturing the infant and
therefore it makes sense
that mom continue to nurture the infant
through parental behavior.
What about males?
In most mammalian species,
a very large subset of mammalian species,
the males actually attack the infants.
Attack them sometime or very
often actually kill them.
This infanticidal behavior has been widely
observed in many animal species.
It is thought that this is actually
an evolutionary driven aggressive behavior
of the males in order to gain access
to the females that are not accessible
when they are nurturing their own infant.
Interestingly, this is a behavior
that is absent in monogamous species
in which both the male and the female
are nurturing their infant and therefore
there is not this conflict of access
of the male to the female.
Infant neglect and aggression is also
occasionally displayed
by distressed female.
This is seen in animals
as well as I mentioned
in post-partum depression
and psychosis in human.
We're not working with human,
we're not working wit primates,
we're working with mice.
And in mice, there is in
this animal species I mention
a very clear sexual dimorphism in
the behavior of animal male
and female towards infants.
Females even virgin females,
or sexually inexperienced females,
spontaneously take care of infants.
They will build a nest, they
will lick and groom the pups,
retrieve them to the nest and
huddle around the infants.
Virgin males in contrast
will spontaneously
attack infants, wound
them and kill them through
infanticidal behavior.
Very, very different set of behavior.
However males are not always infanticidal
and in fact and strikingly
males after mating
with the female are no
longer infanticidal.
The video I would like to show you here
is from _ certified infanticidal male.
This male attacked infants
three weeks earlier
and then we had that
male mating with a female
and then we are testing
the behavior of this male
now with these pups.
As you can see, the male has built a nest
and now is retrieving
these pups one by one.
And I should mention by the way that these
are not the pups of that particular male.
This behavior will be displayed towards
any infant that is
to which they are exposed.
All the pups are now
collected to the nest.
And as you see this is a really good dad,
he's checking that it has
not forgotten any pups.
Nobody left, good.
Let's go back to the nest and
then take care of the pups.
So this is a really
fascinating switch in behavior
that really indicate that
even in infanticidal males,
there's the ability for
these males to be parental.
How is this happening?
Evolutionary speaking, this is
actually not that surprising
because if you look at
various animal species,
insects, fish, amphibians,
reptiles, birds and mammals,
there are species in which the female
is always the one handling the progeny.
You can see little eggs here
and little larva over here.
Here's a tadpole on the back of that frog.
But very similar species,
genetically very similar
show animal in which
there's biparental care.
So both the male and the female handle
the nurturing of the progeny.
And similarly also very
similar species genetically
have the male that exclusively
takes care of the progeny.
For example this beetle here
with the little eggs here,
or this male amphibian who's a tadpole,
or here this fascinating
monkey, the Titi monkey
in which the male is actually
providing exclusive care
of the infant.
So what's happening here?
In mice, what's happening is that
there's a dominate male
that mates with the female
and the female have a communal nest.
This male is always parental.
However subordinate males that do not have
access to the female are infanticidal.
Will tend to attack
the male, kill the pups
and that in turn enable
them to mate with the female
and at that time, they become parental.
From a neuroscience
standpoint, this is fascinating
because what it shows is that the brain
has actually two types of circuits.
One driving infanticidal behavior
that is displayed by virgin males,
and one that drive parenting behavior
but is displayed by females and fathers.
The question we're very interested in is
what are these neurons that control
parenting and infanticidal behavior?
What I would like to tell you today
is how are we able to identify neurons
that are necessary and
sufficient to drive parenting
behavior both in males and in females.
What we use is a way
to identify molecularly
neurons that are active
during a certain behavior.
And the idea is that when a neuron
is firing action potential,
they are changing their gene expression.
And in particular they turn on particular
geno transcription factor called cFos.
So if have a female or a
male interacting with pups,
then the neurons that
are involved in parenting
will fire and therefore they
will express this gene cFos.
So if we look at the brain
of parenting animals,
both males and females
compared to infanticidal male,
we find that there is a
subpopulation of neurons
in one particular area of the
brain in the hypothalamus,
in the area called the
medial preoptic area
in which you see these
very dense collection
of neurons that express this gene cFos
after the animals has
interacted with pups.
Both males and females.
This is very interesting.
It's actually not that surprising
because already in the 50s, 60s, 70s,
a number of groups
through lesion experiment
have shown that maternal behavior requires
the function of the medial preoptic area.
What we really would like to know
is which precisely, what
precisely are the nature,
the identity of these neurons
that are cFos positive.
In fact this area, the
medial preoptic area,
fulfill a lot of function.
It's involved in mating
behavior, thermo sensation,
also the odd function of parenting.
So knowing precisely and specifically
which of the neurons that express cFos
is something that we really need to know
if we want to understand the
control of parenting behavior.
We tested the number of candidate genes
and we found to our delight
one particular gene,
the gene that encodes for
the neuro peptide galanin
as being very nicely
co expressed with Cfos
when the animal are parenting.
Interestingly the number of galanin cells
in the medial preoptic
area is identical in males
and females, in virgin males
and in virgin males and mothers.
In fact, in other words,
these neurons are there
in the male and the
female brain irrespective
of whether these neurons
are parenting or not.
Now galanin is a peptide
expressed in many different areas.
It's been involved in
many different functions
such as nociception, sleep,
thermoregulation, etc.
So we don't know whether galanin has
any role to do to play
in parenting behavior.
But the fact that we
know one genetic marker
gives us genetic tools.
In other words, we are
able to use a genetic line
that express this enzyme called Cre.
Think about the scissor if you wish
that enable to activate
specific molecular tool
to manipulate the activity of neurons.
The experiment that we've done is
to inject a conditional toxin into
the preoptic area of a galanin Cre mouse.
And what this does is that it enabled us
to kill specifically these galanin neurons
present in the medial preoptic area.
No other neurons outside of the brain
or within the MPOA,
nothing else than this specific galanin
expressing cells are affected.
What's happening when we test the behavior
of females and fathers
when we kill galanin
neurons in the medial preoptic area.
The effect is very striking.
The ablation of these MPOA galanin neurons
entirely abolishes both
maternal and paternal behavior
and actually elicits infanticide.
So they seen to be a role of these neurons
not only in driving parenting behavior
but actually inhibiting
infant mediated aggression.
Now we tried the other experiment,
a sufficiency experiment
which is if we know
take an aggressive male
and activate artificially galanin neurons
in these infanticidal
males, what's happening?
What's happening and we
performed this experiment
using a technique called optogenetics
that enable to express a
light activated channel
in the neurons and then
using an optic fiber
to activate these cells.
And what we find when we shine light
and activate these galanin neurons is that
infanticidal male are
no longer infanticidal
and instead display paternal behavior.
So what this shows is that these specific
population of neurons are both necessary
and sufficient for the
control of parental behavior
in both males and females.
Parental behavior is a complex behavior
and what we'd like to do now is really
to understand this behavior
in mechanistic terms.
These neurons as we've seen
are able to control parenting.
Parenting means a lot of things,
grooming, licking, crouching, retrieving,
nest building, and then
inhibiting infanticidal behavior.
But these neurons do all of
these according obviously
to the presence of an
infant but also according
to the physiological state.
Male for example will
either trigger this behavior
or not trigger this behavior according to
whether they are fathers or not.
What we would like to understand
is how are all these different
display being performed?
And what is the role of this environment
in the activity of these neurons?
The first set of
experiment that we've done
is really try to understand
whether these galanin neurons
really are involved in all
these different part of parenting.
The experiment that
I'm gonna show you here
is what is called bulk
imaging or volume imaging
or these galanin neurons.
The idea is that these
neurons now are expressing
a genetically encoded
indicator of neural activity.
So these neurons are now
gonna emit fluorescence
when they are active and only
in these particular area.
And what we're gonna have,
we have an optic probe
that enable to visualize
the intensity of the signal.
So it's called bulk imaging because
we don't have cellular resolution.
In other words we're
looking at the activity
of all these neurons together.
And so what you see here is a female
and here a bunch of pups over there.
The animal has an optic fiber here
and what you can see here is
the level of calcium.
And as the female approaches the pups,
you can see the level of calcium going up.
And she's licking the pups
and indeed the level of
calcium stays high and as she
brings the pup to the nest
and starts licking the pup,
then the level of calcium
is really going out the roof.
Interestingly we found that all the paths
composing parenting behavior
involve this galanin neuron.
So that's quite interesting.
Now I'm gonna show you another video
in which this female
here has a very similar
type of behavior as you can see.
She's grooming something, licking.
Then she's gonna bring
that thing to the nest
exactly how she's done with the pups,
but as you can see here,
the level of signal
is completely flat.
What's happening?
Well although the behavior looks
very much like parenting behavior,
actually she's handling a fish cracker.
(laughter)
And in these circumstances,
galanin neurons are totally silent.
Again although the behavior
looks exactly the same,
what's happening in the
brain, the significance
of this behavior is completely different
and involve very different
parts of the brain.
In summary, we started by the idea that
parenting is an essential behavior
and that in different species
it's displayed differently
by males, by females, sometimes both.
That we were really interested in going
to the cellular molecular
basis of this behavior.
We found this really
interesting system in the mouse
in which animal are or are not parenting
and we found this
fascinating neural cell type,
this MPOA galanin neurons that now really
give us entry into how parenting
behavior is controlled.
What are the different
regulation of these neurons,
what are the sets of projection,
what type of input do they receive,
and how all of these changes
in both during development,
in males, in females and
during mental illness.
I would like to thank the people,
the wonderful collaborator in my lab
who've performed this work.
Thank you.
(applause)
(techno music)